when you have 60 of Americans who
couldn't even absorb a 400 unexpected
expenditure 500 000 people falling into
medical debt every year half of our
seniors living on twenty five thousand
dollars a year and less and on and on
and on the people in this country are in
trouble and the way to win in 2024 is
not for the Democrats to say hey things
are doing well economy is getting better
because people people know what they
know in their gut and they do vote with
their feelings and you can't blame them
for that it makes sense to do that
thank you
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast author spiritual leader and
newly declared Democratic presidential
candidate for 2024 my friend Marianne
Williamson welcome Marianne
hey thank you for having me Andrew it's
great to see you it's great to see you
as well uh we were just reminiscing
about our first meeting about five years
ago when we were both running in the
last cycle uh and first let me salute
you for taking it on again
um because you and I both went through
different Journeys uh I suppose in the
last cycle we share some concerns about
both where the country is and and also
uh who the Democratic nominee is going
to be
be honest I mean
um though though I think our concerns
might might be uh like slightly
different in terms of uh you know I mean
we can get into it but first let me
Salute Your courage your leadership your
patriotism for getting back in the fight
thank you well you're right we both know
what it's like in the belly of that
Beast
so it wasn't an easy decision to make
but I'm sure you agree with me that when
you are up close and personal with that
situation you see both how corrupt the
system can be but also how wonderful
voters can be
I was very impressed by the people that
I met I'm sure you were too you really
experienced when you're running for
president
the goodness and the Dignity of of the
voters
you really do see that that's not where
the problem lies the problem lies is
with the political media industrial
complex that uh works very hard and
assiduously to sometimes suppress
basically the will of the people and
that's what we need to deal with that's
what you're seeking to deal with in your
way and I'm seeking to deal with them my
way and that millions of your listeners
are seeking to deal with in their own
way because it's a it's a societal
breakdown and people realize it and we
need to change it yeah so on the media
industrial complex uh and I've written
and spoken about how I thought they were
deeply unfair to you why do you think
that is like I was talking to Evelyn
about it we think a lot of it is uh the
fact that your woman
it also might be that you're a genuinely
independent actor but to the extent that
you have a theory as to why it seems
like reporters uh don't give you a fair
Shake uh where have you landed well
first of all I want to be clear that
many did or I don't know many did but
some did and I I want to have a space in
my mind for the possibility that even
though some of those who didn't might
change their ways this time so I don't
want to you know and I don't have a chip
on my shoulder that was then and this is
now but I do think that there is a
group of people in this country who have
a predetermined agenda for where they
think the country should go and it's the
replacement of the will of the people
really by a kind of political class very
paternalistic it thinks that it knows I
don't know what they're so proud of
we're six inches from the cliff in terms
of the state of our democracy the state
of our environment the state of our city
the state of our everything so I don't
know what they're so proud of that they
should be declaring that only that only
those who drove us into this ditch could
possibly be considered qualified enough
to lead us out of it but they do not
only do they have a predetermined agenda
but they have a predetermined set of
people who they consider
um the ones who even should have the
right to effectuate that agenda and of
course you see what happened with Bernie
Sanders as well as you as well as me I
think it's the deepest level it's our
politics we could talk about the
misogyny and we could talk about a
distrust of anything that has to do with
any anything whole person or spiritual
as opposed to strictly transactional but
I think at the deepest level what
they're concerned about is a more
Progressive uh political Vision making
its way into the central leadership
establishment of how the Democratic
party presents itself to the country
well I will share a person a personal
story I interviewed a producer a former
MSNBC producer named Ariana bakari have
you run across Ariana at all Marianne I
don't know not that I know of you would
like her so she left MSNBC in part
because she said hey I don't think that
we're doing right by the public
and she shared a detail that I found
very personally relevant she said that
she was given a list of presidential
candidates never to have on air
hello and I was on that list obviously
so I was like oh that's not very cool
um but but then it does make you think
it's like who the heck is coming up with
that list why are they then sending it
to producers and presumably anchors
saying like hey don't interview these
people yeah I remember during the last
campaign when Vogue magazine did a
spread of all the women candidates I was
a woman candidate and I was left out of
the of the story and also you're saying
right now actually polls online of them
are Democratic possibilities I'm the
only one who's actually declarified
other than the obvious you know
inevitability of the Biden we assume of
the Biden campaign
Aaron I'm not listed on there but you
know what the difference is this time
people are noticing that that's what I
think is interesting I think that
there's been a kind of Awakening uh on
all kinds of levels among the American
people over the last few years I don't
think that people will take as easily to
that uh obvious Mission distraction
distraction technique
um I hope not anyone so I referenced
concerns about Joe Biden uh I think 60
of Democrats that were polled said
they'd prefer that he does not run for
re-election again and yet there is this
massive conventional wisdom from
kind of the journalist class or the
political class or some combination that
running against Joe is quote unquote
enabling Trump or or something along the
the those those lines
um I will share with you my my concerns
about Joe
um that I I think that it's and the
average American is troubled by the fact
that he might simply not be up to the
task of running the country for another
four years uh based upon his Vitality
his Acuity his
um age uh and some people say oh that's
Aegis to even suggest that
um the average American I speak to
thinks that 82 might be too old to be
heading into your second term uh and I
so I I think that in my mind it would be
very healthy to have some kind of
competitive primary determining the next
generation of leaders of the party
um I I think that Joe has done a lot as
president but I don't think he's the
right fit for 2025 for and I think that
a younger version of him would recognize
that
um so that that's my standpoint I will
say that I'm very
uh supportive of your run
um one on a personal level because you
and I are friends two I think your
vision for the country is very positive
and and uh healthy and I'm aligned with
you in a lot of the things you want to
see for people in communities uh but
three I do think there should be a
competitive primary because I I think
the fix being in for Joe
um has the potential to leave us in a
really really rough spot as a country so
I'm just sharing my thinking
um and I don't know which of those
elements
[Laughter]
like you agree with take issue with well
the only conventional wisdom that should
matter
democracy like you said a majority of
Democrats have said that they would like
to hear other voices the idea of
engineering the primary session uh so
that
Joe Biden has an easier time winning and
the field is cleared of anyone who might
wish to run against him is undemocratic
it Harkens back to a time when a bunch
of men sat around the table smoking
cigars and just deciding who they
thought the nominee should be if in fact
the voters in the Democratic primary
considering all the issues that you said
considering the pros and the cons
decided yes I think that Joe Biden
should be the the person that the
Democratic party nominates to go up to
what is probably obviously either Trump
or DeSantis then God bless him it should
be Joe Biden but it should be for the
people to decide that's the point that
seems so important to me we either
believe in democracy or we don't and um
it's to me if some people would see his
age as an issue some people would not
see his age as an issue I think the
bigger issue here has to do with the
vision of the country and what agenda is
going to be strong enough not only the
person but also the agenda to present to
the American people as an alternative to
what the GOP is going to be throwing at
us in 2024. I think a lot of people say
well he was the man for 2020 he defeated
Trump and all that's true but that
doesn't it doesn't it's not a necessary
uh uh conclusion based on that that he
is the person to beat Trump or DeSantis
in 2024 and it should be the people who
decide well certainly I love the sound
of that I love the sound of people
actually getting to decide uh democracy
foreign
I've always been a mattress guy it's one
reason I'm so thrilled that this podcast
is sponsored by Helix sleep Helix sleep
is the future of mattresses you take the
Helix sleep quiz at their website and
get your perfect mattress fit in under
two minutes it takes a little longer for
them to get that to your door but when
they send it to your door you get a
hundred night free trial I know it's
crazy that's over three months and then
over a 10-year warranty to try out your
new Helix mattress it's become the go-to
mattress for my kids in the house and
they have a few mattresses to choose
from but they just always seem to find
this one you don't need to take my kids
word for it it's also the number one
mattress pick by wired GQ imagine that
job just trying out mattresses for
magazines but it's number one and it's
number one for a reason Helix is
offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com yang
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now
[Music]
foreign
thing I've heard about people being
uncomfortable with Joe running for
reelection is that it could very much
lead to president Kamala Harris
um in in a way that did not reflect the
will of the people she was in the same
cycle you and I were and then she
dropped out uh before the the voting
started there's a lot of concern or
ambivalence around her being president
in a way that frankly to me would be
somewhat you know not stamped by the
popular will and one idea that's come up
that I personally like a lot is that
maybe there should be a primary for the
running mate so that the will of the
people can be expressed in uh who might
end up the next president uh especially
if it is Joe again because you know
Joe's getting up in years
well there is a historical precedent for
that it's actually a modern phenomenon
that the candidate chooses the vice
president the way we do Lincoln did not
choose Andrew Johnson for instance
Andrew Johnson was chosen because uh he
was from a Southern state but he was
supporting the union
um Franklin D Roosevelt he uh he wanted
him to Wallace to continue and it was
the other than the Democratic party who
knew how precarious Roosevelt's Health
was Etc who then went for Truman so it's
not historically aberrational on the
other hand when you say we should have a
primary to choose the vice president if
they're already trying to rig the
primary for president what makes us
think they wouldn't rig the primary for
vice president and choose who their boy
Pete Buddha judge or one or the other so
the idea conceptually is fine but I
wouldn't trust the process on that one
necessarily any more than I trust the
process
regarding the presidential but yes
you're you're right this is certainly
the kind of thing people are having to
think about in this election yeah I
think in the very old days originally
the person who got the second most votes
was vice president
certainly are like are different ways to
go you and I I became friends on the
trail did you spend any time with
President Biden when he was candidate
Biden on the trail I wouldn't say I
spent time with him I met him a few
times he was he was lovely he was
perfectly polite kind respectful his
wife I think is particularly Charming I
met some of his family I thought they
were lovely this is not personal I'm not
taking any personal pot shots at Joe
Biden that's not what this is about for
me at all no I was just curious because
I also spent time with uh him and and
Jill unless I was family members but
they were also always very warm and
positive lovely people lovely people uh
you know I I think that's one of the
issues and it sounds like you and I have
a slightly different take on it but I
like like I think that Joe was the right
candidate for 2020
um but yeah well obviously he was yeah
obviously
nobody's doubting that and all credit
where credit is due yeah but I also
think you know that's not that that's
not necessarily true in 2024 personally
well not only that I think there's more
than that as well for me which is yes we
didn't fall over the cliff by electing
Trump but we're still six inches away
from the cliff that's true
and I don't think that you know I I
think of the Biden agenda you know
particularly if if the Biden
Administration plans to come at the 2024
elections uh with a message to the
American people that the economy is
doing well the unbelievable disconnect
between whatever Geniuses and whatever
DC think tanks will come up with a
message like that versus the visceral
experience of the majority of Americans
64 percent of whom are living paycheck
to paycheck just shows the that you know
Washington it I've always heard it was a
bubble it's more than a bubble it's a
walled off City it's a you you don't
know what's going on in this country if
you're going to go submit to the
American people that the economy is
doing well which by the way means that
you learn nothing from 2016. so what I
see in in Joe Biden is the effort to
help people
survive a basically unjust economic
system the what I wish to submit to the
American people is that this
Administration will end the unjust
system it's not enough to just help
people survive we should the government
should be helping people thrive and that
would mean more than shaving off a
little College loan here getting a
little bit more to Obamacare over there
it would mean Universal Health Care it
would mean free College
tuition-free college and and tech school
it would mean 3 child care it would mean
Paid Family Leave it would mean a
guaranteed livable ways it's business if
we're going to take these incremental
approaches and give you a little bit
here and a little bit there it still
amounts of the Republicans offering you
crumbs the Democrats offering you a
cookie and I think every American should
be able to Feast on the rights and the
opportunities economic and otherwise
that are afforded by the richest country
in the world that's a vision of
abundance that at the vision of
abundance and we have abundance that's
the thing we have abundance the issue is
who has the abundance so over the last
48 years
sure you're aware we have had a massive
transfer of wealth which is really a
nice way of putting institutional theft
a 50 trillion dollars that have gone
from the bottom ninety percent of
Americans are the top one percent we
have plenty of wealth in this country
it's who holds it it's held by very few
people and we have policy after policy
both in terms of our tax structures in
terms of our corporate subsidies
that actually make it easier for those
who already have to get more and makes
it harder for the average American to
even make it when you have 60 of
Americans who couldn't even absorb a 400
unexpected expenditure 500 000 people
falling into medical debt every year
half of our seniors living on twenty
five thousand dollars a year and less
and on and on and on the people in this
country are in trouble and the way to
win in 2024 is not for the Democrats to
say hey things are doing well economy is
getting better because people people
know what they know in their gut and
they do vote with their feelings and you
can't blame them for that it makes sense
to do that we are the wealthiest country
in the history of the world and we
should be able to do a lot better uh by
our people than we're doing right now so
you reference DC as a Walled Garden uh
and you've been spending more time in DC
over the last few years uh what what uh
have you gotten out of that uh because
I've never lived in DC I'm curious what
your experience has been well people
people
are everywhere and there's some
wonderful people here but it's also
interestingly Ground Zero isn't it for
some of the people you have three times
the amount of corporate lobbyists that
you have legislators in this town so
some of the people who are welcome
so some of the forces that are making
what you and I would consider the most
nefarious plans for how Healthcare
should operate in this country how food
should operate in this country how
energy should operate in this country
how foreign policy should operate in
this country some of the people who
represent obesis to the bottom line of
corporate profit maximization for huge
corporate entities even at the expense
of the workers at the expense of Health
well-being and Safety and Security of
people animal and planets they are
headquartered here
but also headquartered here are people
who are
doing their darndest to try to make it
better some of whom are the brave
exceptions to the corporatist uh Bunch
which runs the government but also ngos
staff members so you meet both here it's
kind of ground zero and also I think you
said something before Andrew that I
think is important for us to note you
said given that we are the richest
country in the world we should be able
to do better no we can do better they
choose not to do better remember when
you're talking about things like
Universal Health Care livable wage paid
family leave these things are considered
moderate positions
in most advanced democracies so we have
one group of people here who just don't
care about that and the other group of
people who say it's complicated and it's
not complicated it's corrupt
so if you have you know if you have
some leaders basically within the
Republican Party who just don't care to
solve all that gargantuan sea of
economic despair out there but then you
have others who don't have the spine to
fix it who don't have the moral courage
to fix it we need to get in there people
who are not part of that system and say
that we will
that's why I'm running
so spending time in DC how do people
react to you if you're just hanging out
in the street do you show up to an event
I mean I these day-to-day experiences
human beings live here you know that I
mean and some of the people that I like
here you know they don't they don't
agree with me politically either you
know there's you know I have some real
neoliberal friends who you know I I you
know I don't I I'm pretty good at
compartmentalizing in my mind when it
comes to personal relationships which I
which I don't I think has been some sort
of lost you know I'm told that in DC
people used to break bread and have
drinks together from uh different
parties uh different ideological lanes
and then now that happens less uh you
know which sounds like a bad way for
things to go I'd also note that I
believe Washington DC is now the
wealthiest County in the country uh per
capita which I don't think was the case
when I was growing up I feel like that's
a relatively recent phenomenon well when
you were growing up citizens united had
not given corporations unlimited power
to send their lobbyists into this town
and make clear what they wanted to have
happen
if you know me you know that I think
that our data should be ours and that
big Tech right now is running roughshod
on our autonomy our agency our privacy
for sure one way to help turn the tables
on big Tech is to use expressvpn like I
do when I surf the web it keeps you
private by piping you in to another IP
address it's what big companies use it
was rated the number one VPN that's
virtual private Network by CNET wired
and more let's take it back from Big
Tech Stop handing over your personal
data to the quasi-monopolies that mine
our activity and sell our info for their
profit not ours protect yourself with a
VPN I trust to keep me and mine safe
online visit expressvpn.com Yang that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com to get three extra
months free
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
foreign
so I I'm putting myself in your shoes
because you know we we have direct
experience running for president last
time you and I spent a lot of time in
Iowa
um which may or may not even you know be
an early State I mean we're not sure
um you just went up to New Hampshire
which will be an early State I think the
odds are high that New Hampshire is the
first state to go but that the DNC will
be mad about that because the DNC is
trying to uh Advantage uh Joe and put
South Carolina first
um what have your experiences been like
going back to New Hampshire uh and how
do you see yourself spending your time
uh over this next number of months
making the case
well New Hampshire rights are angry
understandably I mean I can't speak for
every New Hampshire right but many of
them uh I can assure you think what Joe
Biden has done there is wrong I mean
it's such an obvious engineering I mean
Joe Biden did not do well in New
Hampshire so let's put New Hampshire
aside Joe Biden did well in South
Carolina he has James Clyburn and others
Jamie Harrison and all of that so I
think this is just one of the many ways
in which people are seeing through
you know this this The Wizard of Oz here
and people are are not okay with it so
I'll certainly be in New Hampshire New
Hampshire has a tradition of being very
open to Independent candidates and more
recently very open to Progressive
candidates so it shouldn't be Joe
Biden's or the dnc's uh decision whether
or not and it's and it's not clearly
that's part of their state constitution
so New Hampshire will be first I will be
there and I will be hoping and I will
certainly be stating so the Joe Biden is
planning to debate me if in fact he
announces which I assume that he will be
there should be a free Marketplace of
ideas Joe Biden is is is planning to
offer in 2024 the alleviation of stress
and I don't think that the alleviation
of stress is enough to offer the
American people we need to offer genuine
economic reform so I will be out there
saying it whether it's in New Hampshire
South Carolina Michigan Georgia Nevada
um and like you said we don't know
what's going to happen with Iowa and I'm
I'm sure that you and I both I'm sure we
had this same experience it's fun being
out there you know when people have
asked me what it was like running for
president last time I said it was like
equal measure brutality and exhilaration
the the media the meanness the stuff
online all that is brutal it's painful
and then talking to to voters and really
regulations to the yearnings and that
and yeah and the visions of the average
American is is a wonderful experience so
I'm looking forward to it I had to get
to that point you know where like yeah
yeah those were the best times
um hanging out with everyday voters in
the early States who just want to make
things better uh and in the best of
cases they actually start to see you as
someone who's in their corner and wants
to solve the problems uh half of I think
when people showed up to those events
they just want to say are you for real
are you genuine are you you know
are you actually on our side and when
they concluded it's like I think this
person's sincere then it goes a long way
well your your stump speech was truly
gray I mean that was
what you presented and I remember
sitting in the audience and I were going
wow
yeah no it's true it's absolutely true I
think that in the last election people
were understandably in a place of we
just want to beat Trump we just want to
beat Trump but I think this time people
are
first of all people are open I believe I
certainly hope to to a real conversation
suggesting that what could beat Trump in
2020 might not be what would be Trump in
2024. and it might not be Trump in 2024
there's like a very strange Santos or
any of them or any of them any of them
yeah I agree with
that the folks in New Hampshire are bent
out of shape rightfully because they did
everything right last time as far as I
can tell they got out and forced they
had a well-run primary they didn't vote
for Joe Biden which didn't know that
that's what they did wrong
as far as the DNC is concerned I mean
it's so obvious it's so overt I can't
even believe they don't even pretend
anymore you know the the DNC is supposed
to stay neutral until after the
primaries and I think personally that if
they had done that in 2016 either
Hillary or Bernie would have won the uh
nomination but either way I don't think
Trump would have ever been president
but they do what they do yeah the the
DNC is not an impartial actor I mean we
all know they were in the tank for
Hillary and that that cycle at this time
you know they're clearly engineering the
process to protect Joe as much as
possible one of the things I think is
painful about doing New Hampshire
Democrats dirty is that's a freaking
swing state you know what I mean like
it's hard to be like hey you guys don't
matter so much but oh you got to get out
and vote uh you know save my life yeah
yeah and I think
but there are so many people that were
told you have to you have to vote for us
because you'll get your student debt
canceled well not really you have to
vote for us because the um the higher
minimum wage will make sure you get a
higher minimum wage well not really
because the parliamentarian was against
it so we're going to hide behind her
skirts we're going to take care of the
environment yeah but then we've given
more uh drilling permits uh Biden has
given more dwelling permits than even
Trump did yeah we're going to codify uh
Roe v Wade yeah we're going to have
police reform all kinds of things that
were promised and I don't know how uh I
mean I'm not giving strategic advice to
the by the administration obviously but
I don't know how they plan to go back to
people who were willing to stand in line
for seven and eight hours
well we didn't give you well we gave you
a little of it or in some cases none of
it and expect those people to be willing
to stand in line again no we need
something different there is no
corporatist Democratic message that is
going to beat the Republicans in 2024
but I think I can and um otherwise I
wouldn't be running so one of the
Dynamics I think that's used to justify
uh having South Carolina First in New
Hampshire and Iowa not
um is that South Carolina is more
diverse New Hampshire is predominantly
white Iowa is predominantly white and
there's an argument that that's not
representative of the country it's not
representative of the democratic party
uh on the flip side you and I spent a
lot of time in Iowa in particular and it
it pains me that Iowa has gone from a
quintessential swing state uh purple to
red plus nine so has Iowa for that
matter and the national Democratic party
is essentially saying look
rural white Midwestern State you know we
are not going to be investing in you
anymore uh and the New Hampshire picture
then gets a little bit uh
more negative I would say because it's
sending a similar message and again New
Hampshire you know like that they
um they've done everything right as far
as I can tell
um but one of the things that pains me
about is that it accelerates or
increases the polarization uh between
the two parties where if you say to
certain types of Voters it's like well
you know sorry we're a white
midwesterner is not a priority for the
Democratic party anymore we're going to
go to diversifying areas and then the
people that are in those States still
including the Whatever It Is 40 uh you
know one percent of Iowans who are still
Democrats are looking up saying wait a
minute like what what just happened
in addition to everything else it's
stupid you know when uh Lyndon Johnson
signed civil rights legislation he said
we just lost the South for a generation
he didn't say we just lost it for 50
years he said we lost it for a
generation and when the Democratic party
in just the way that you said just kind
of blew off the South that was
ridiculous you don't just give ground
like that and now you're talking about
giving ground in certain rural States
Etc the Democratic party should be
standing for Rural America this
Democratic party should be standing for
Southern America if
um uh the American South and and the
problems the deepest problems in the
rural communities as well as in the
American South are economic problems the
Democratic party needs to return to its
traditional value of unabashed advocacy
for the working people of the United
States not just the managerial Elite I
mean it's it's stupid on top of
everything else but it's also a a a a a
swing away from the principles on which
we purport to stand and you know it's
also very dangerous because Franklin
Roosevelt said that we would not have to
worry about a fascist or authoritarian
takeover as long as democracy delivered
on its blessings so here is the DNC and
the Democratic Elite who say to someone
like me you can't do this you shouldn't
do this because somebody primary Biden
you know all this it's so big enough to
be primary Biden last time that happened
Jimmy Carter lost what Ronald Reagan had
nothing to do with that you're going to
blame the whole thing on Teddy Kennedy
that to me is like saying my uncle died
of cancer and he ate an apple that
morning so Apple's about I mean it's
just absurd but more importantly the
problem if we have an authoritarian
threat in our midst which we do the
issue is not to suppress democracy the
issue is to use democracy to stand for
democracy and that's why I'm saying that
we should be offering to the American
people the genuine economic reform which
would be the embodiment of a genuinely
Democrat agenda I agree with you that
the way to make us more resilient to
authoritarianism that is a very real
threat is more democracy not less
exactly
and you know I've been championing
things like non-partisan primaries and
ranked Choice voting that I think would
truly open the system up your uh
sympathetic to those reforms is that
right oh absolutely right choice voting
I think is really important and listen
you and I both know about the importance
of third parties in American history
abolition came from the Abolitionist
party women's suffrage came from the
women's party Civil Rights Movement
obviously came from the southern uh
Christian Leadership Council the
greatest social movement social justice
movements in the United States did not
emerge from the two major parties we all
know the history they're not mentioned
in the Constitution John Adams said they
could be the greatest threat to
democracy they could form in
Washington's words a faction of men more
concerned with their party than with
their country so I think that efforts
such as yours are important I think each
of us though you know Gandhi said that
the Indian independence movement was led
by the small still voice within each of
us has to follow our own heart our own
God where do you feel you can make the
biggest difference so to me it's not
either or some people will feel moved
such as you to work outside the two
major parties to bolster a significant
third party uh and listen we know that
the Democrats and the Republicans have
formed a very Unholy Alliance making it
very very difficult for anyone but them
to even be in the conversation that's
true but it's also true that the
Democratic party in its history has been
a powerful a powerful stand of the
working people of the United States for
the average American and the principles
on which we stand my heart leads me to
work there including I know the efforts
to invisibilize me and I think it'll be
much easier to do if I run third party
so I'm standing up for my nostalgic
memories of what the Democratic party
once was and still can be
thank you
oh I I had a similar experience to you
where I was running in Iowa I was in a
diner uh and I said to the waitress uh I
am I'm Andrew Young and I'm running for
president and she said oh really which
party and then I said Democrat and then
she was like oh and like but you know
recoiled like I'd said something uh
dirty and I thought that was super sad
because in theory the Democratic party
is standing for people like her and
somehow she does not think that the
Democratic party stands for people like
her I've read a couple of articles about
how if you see where people stand on
issues they're more in favor of
democratic issues just don't tell them
it's supported by the Democratic Party
you know the vast majority of Americans
want Universal Health Care what
free child care want tuition free
college they just don't like the
association of those things more with
the Democratic party than with not
without and that means the Democratic
party needs to look at itself in the
mirror and make some changes and not
look at candidates like me who would say
hey let's really become the core
traditional embodiment of the of those
values within the Democratic party and
try to shove us out it's so interesting
to me that the corporatist Democrats
look at someone who is Progressive like
we're trying to take over the party they
took over the party we're Franklin and
Eleanor they're the duponts and the
Morgans so well I I'm with you on the
fact that uh
there are different approaches uh to try
and make things better and I you know I
I endorse anyone who's trying to make
something good happen
um whether it's within the context of
the democratic party or the Republican
party or any party or a forward party so
you're going on this journey
um you and I both know what the journey
is about
um I you know I hope to join you at some
point on the trail I hope you will I'd
be honored if you would thank you yeah
yeah we'll have some fun together we'll
have some uh you know we were on stage
in Iowa together
yeah yeah we were and you know I feel
like you and I saw each other literally
like I mean or like you know dozens of
times I mean I don't know if it got up
to that level but I think it really
might have it was always a great time I
like I always enjoyed spending time with
you and like you said the best time on
the trail is when you're actually
talking to real live voters who are
trying to make a decision for themselves
um you should know when I was in South
Carolina last month there were a bunch
of people there who wanted a competitive
primary uh and they wanted a competitive
primary because uh they wanted some
energy and resources to their state by
the way the red wave that everyone says
missed the country actually hit in a few
places in November uh it hit in Florida
it hit in New York and it hit in South
Carolina where the the Democrats there
are
really feeling themselves to be the
minority party in a very significant way
and so then they look up and say well
we've got a lot of cloud in the National
stage because we're going to be the
first in the nation the primary but then
they say wait a minute there there might
not be that much energy around this
primary if Joe you know is coronated so
the South Carolina Democrats I spoke to
said that they very much want uh there
to be like a genuine competition and
there were a few people there who said
that they would prefer it if Joe didn't
run which isn't surprising given that I
think that's the Viewpoint of a majority
of Democrats well I will certainly be
offering them an alternative I can't
control who they vote for that this is
democracy but what I can control is
whether people will be offered an
alternative to the neoliberal
corporate-backed political agenda that
the Democrats in far too many cases
represent yeah and that is uh exactly
why I admire your run so much is that
the people deserve a choice absolutely
and and I think that there are a dozen
major Democratic political figures who
look in the mirror and think to
themselves I would I would be a great
president who are not going to run and
the reason they're not going to run is
not because they think it's the right
thing for the country uh it's because
they've been convinced that it's the
right thing for them
that someone tells you everything you
need to know so if they're bowing down
to the DNC even in their decision
whether or not to run what kind of
President would they be right if they're
already showing that they're not putting
first what they actually think is best
for the country so hey you know I read
somewhere somebody said that if I if I
run I'm committing political suicide and
I thought what kind of political career
do I have to you know that I can kill
and that's why I think in all
seriousness someone from outside the
system is really what these times demand
the status quo will not disrupt itself
this the political status quo is so
imbued with the undue influence of
corporate money and corporate power at
this point that I think the real
disruption of the system will come from
someone outside you know
this idea that only one of them should
be considered qualified only people
who's whose careers have been entrenched
in the car which drove us into the ditch
should be considered qualified to lead
us out of it I think that's absurd and I
think people are seeing it I also think
that Washington you were talking about
this town it's filled with political car
mechanics and many of them are very good
political car mechanics the problem
though is that we're on the wrong road
and that goes back to Franklin Roosevelt
saying that the primary job of the
presidency is not administrative it's
not technical it's moral leadership so I
think that people are open to that and
the one of the things that interests me
is that in the U.S Constitution is I'm
sure you're aware the qualifications for
uh the president are 35 years old born
here lived here for 14 years now if the
founders had wanted to say had to have
been a senator Congressman lawyer
Governor they would have they were
leaving it to every generation to
determine for itself what is the skill
set what are the qualifications that you
think are most required at this time to
face the challenges of your generation
and I think someone who's not connected
to that who doesn't see my career
interests there
I mean I think part of what I do bring
is more important than what I don't
bring I'm going to share a story from DC
that I used to tell on the trail which
is that I went there in 2017 talking
about the fourth Industrial Revolution
in Automation and uh what was
the government going to do about it and
it was a very senior mechanic in your
words who said to me Andrew you're in
the wrong town because this is not a
town of leaders this is a town of
followers absolutely they know it and
the only way we're going to do anything
about it is if you create a wave in
other parts of the country and bring
that wave crashing down our heads in DC
that's the only way they don't even I
went around saying well that that's what
we're here to do here to create the wave
let's go but this is the problem they're
delusional they don't seem to realize
how close the crowd is to the gates of
the Bastille they think they're safe
whether the the crowd cannot take it
anymore or the crowd is willing to take
it because they're safe Bill Gates's
grandchildren will be fine no matter
what so that's such a smug thing to say
to you oh go create it elsewhere and
then maybe we will change but you're
right they they are this is a town of
followers rather than leaders and the
message that needs to emerge at this
time which would represent a real U-turn
we've got to close the Aboriginal
chapter of neoliberal economics in order
to begin a new more just Society in the
in this city by the way I thought your
book you know your book were on normal
people was so good and I read it during
the campaign and you introduced me to a
lot of ideas that are more in the air
now but I hadn't even thought about
when I when I first read your book
it's uh this issue of AI is huge so if
I'm ever president you got a job because
uh we do need to face the things that
you've been saying we need to face at a
much deeper level and the voice that you
represent there even though they weren't
ready or willing to let you in
um it's a very necessary Niche well AI
is speeding up have you played with chat
GPT in the in the gang Marianne because
like AI now is scaring the out of a
lot of people I don't know well
this Bing conversation did you read
about all that oh my God it's truly
terrifying truly terrifying they should
shut that thing down not the government
should shut it down Microsoft should
shut it down that's what so outrageous
the lack of Ethics in people in so many
Industries where their economic bottom
line their short short-term profit
maximization is overrides everything
else it's sociopathic
sociopathic it whether you're an
economic system or an individual that
you just don't care
how your actions will affect other human
beings that's sociopathic
well when you talk about the entire
um oh what does it mean to be qualified
what's interesting is that there's
actually now something of an asymmetry
where uh the Republican party is much
more open to less traditional candidates
in part because they've turned on the
media
particular way so the the Trust in Media
among Republicans is only 19 it's crazy
low uh among Independents it's 38 or so
and then among Democrats it's 69 percent
so you have folks in the media in
particular who will present someone as
not qualified and then Democratic
primary voters are more likely to heed
that or listen to it though by the way
the trust is going down for all all uh
parties and all levels I mean like you
know the the the the rise of the uh the
less traditional candidate I think is
going to continue everywhere
um but there there is this set of
holdouts in the Democratic party that
it's not the case in the Republican
party and then there are there are folks
who look at and say well Trump was a
terrible president which I agree with
and he was a non-traditional candidate
um but that that to me doesn't mean that
every non-traditional candidate is
Donald Trump like that that was one of
the things that was presented to me
sometimes it was like have you noticed
that we're different human beings uh
yeah there might be like a vastly
different uh approach here well Abraham
Lincoln was a non-traditional candidate
so you know the Democratic Party
those who are called often the normies
within the Democratic party have an
oddly codependent relationship with the
Democratic Leadership establishment it's
it's odd isn't it meanwhile the
Republicans don't have that you know I
remember in 2016 the RNC said you can
have Jeb Bush John Kasich
Marco Rubio and they said yeah we want
Trump so oddly it's so odd isn't it
because the Democrats have the more
egalitarian policies but the more
elitist relationship to its own
constituency the Republican party has
the elitist policies but the more
egalitarian relationship to its own
constituency even to the point
unfortunately where for crass
you know opportunism on a political
level they had been willing to allow
invoices and keep voices such as you say
right now with Marjorie Taylor green
sitting on a big committee or George
Santos or whomever
um but they are open to a greater array
of voices and um there is an in-between
state where you you don't you don't
celebrate people who are speaking
outside the purview of what should be
considered or a political or democratic
ideals you don't go over there but you
do go into opening you know the
Democrats like to say we're a we're a
wide tent but they don't really mean it
they mean it at that kind of democrat
they say we're a wide tent they mean it
we want you whether you're black whether
you're white whether you're Brown
whether you're Jew whether you're Muslim
whether you're Christian and so forth
but they are not open to the kind of
ideological diversity that the
Democratic party should should represent
you're a spiritual leader and someone
who I'm sure made all sorts of uh
thoughtful deliberations leading up to
this uh you know I I was talking to a
comedian friend of mine and he said that
his job is that the Universe talks to
him and then he talks back
I'm kind of uh Curious whether uh you
grappled with this in a particular way
whether there was any uh sense of and
I'll speak for myself running in 2020 I
just felt like okay I got to do this
thing like that there was like a calling
a stirring
um and it was happening to me when I was
writing the war on normal people the the
book you read and that book kind of
poured out of me it was such a
wonderful writing process when that
happens
um and then after I finished that book
uh I was convicted I said you know what
I'm going to do this like you know I'm
going to run for president
um and I'm going to do my best to try
and help millions and millions of people
uh and and I think you know if you
undertake this kind of Journey like you
have something that either calls you or
stirs within you
um have you been at the same place since
the last one because I will say also
since the last run for me like after I
uh suspended the campaign in New
Hampshire in 2020
um like my my spirit has kind of uh
waxed and waned in different ways
because you know like you wake up some
days and you're like you know like they
could feel differently than others uh
like what has that Arc been like and was
there something that catalyzed you and
said okay I'm doing this again in 24.
well it took me a year just to heal on a
personal level because it's a brutal
experience and it certainly was for me
so for a year I didn't even want to
think about any such thing I just had
personal healing and forgiveness of
myself and others to to work on when it
was it was brought up in conversation
with a friend of mine and that was
followed by a lot of conversation with
him with others
I had my ear to the ground my eye to the
sky and my ear to the ground
how do other people feel and what I get
what is what I'm getting in terms of my
yearning for where America should go is
that shared with other people on the
level that I think it would need to be
shared are people willing to stand on
the agenda of a real U-turn in this
country as a real rejection of
neoliberal Economics there's a real
disruption of the system it's a real
commitment to A New Beginning it's a
real sense of obligation to our
ancestors to our descendants or enough
people is this just me or is this enough
of a lot of other people who I respect
and I took a college tour eight colleges
and universities so I feel I did my due
diligence and I was surrounded by some
really smart people who I respect who
has friends and colleagues really stood
with me in the inquiry I didn't start
out from a place of oh I hope it's true
in fact there was a period of time when
it was very somber for me realizing that
I thought it was true it's like running
into a to a burning building I'm not
naive anymore you're not naive we've
been up close and personal and with the
viciousness of it so yes this was not
something of like hey let's run for
president
um I'm very serious and also I'm not
doing this again just to change the
conversation I'm not doing this to
change the conversation I'm doing it to
win the presidency because those people
who are saying I'll wait till 2028 if
this if if the Earth in front of us do
not go well there might not be
Democratic elections in the United
States in 28 or in 32. so this is the
time and um it's not like I'm the only
one there's nothing like that it's a
collective the Zeitgeist is about
Collective activation
but I do think individuals can be a kind
of tuning fork and I think the president
is a tuning fork
listen Trump was a tuning fork for the
very some of the worst aspects of the
American character and I'd like to be as
president a tuning fork for some of the
dignity and the decency and the
Brilliance of the American people
well you are a true leader in an era
that desperately needs leaders I for one
am very glad that you're running if
someone wants to help support you uh
where do they go how do they do so first
of all thank you Andrew it's an honor
and I'm so deeply grateful for your
generosity uh
marianne2024.com Marianne with two ends
that's
m-a-r-i-a-n-n-e
2024.com
and I hope people will join in and uh
give what you can volunteer be part of
it and uh political Miracles have
happened in this country and they can
happen again well you would be one to
know my friend uh thank you so much for
undertaking this on behalf of all the
people that love you and are with you uh
and I'll see you on the trail uh excited
for you to be kicking off this journey
yet again nothing makes me happier thank
you Andrew much love to you God bless
you honey
[Music]
thank you